hi reg how you doing detour and before
we get into all this triple double talk
I just have a question what if a fan or
viewer in the mid 80s 90s were able to
go back a day later review film call
Commissioner Stern and or Adam Silver
and decide the outcome of a game how
ridiculous is that I mean I I really do
feel for Lexie because I've looked at
that footage over and over again and
again as you know I know zero about golf
I've never golfed I don't know how to
golf but I'm a fan of golfing and when I
look at the video footage to me and
correct me am I wrong is it a matter of
inches that she moves her ball
yes puts her places her I mean matter of
half an inch yeah so number one who ever
called in get a life you must be bored
seriously you've got to get a better
hobby than reviewing a day old
tournament and for them to call in
snitches get stitches
seriously that is ridiculous it was a
matter of inches I could see a foot or I
it's if that happened in the NBA if fans
had the ability to do that that is
ridiculous
well what if somebody calls in and said
you know what I think you need to look
at Bryon Russell being pushed off by
Michael Jordan
like what right okay that what if a fan
called in and because that was okay what
if a fan called it and said Reggie
Miller shelf Michael Jordan on that shot
in Game five or Game six in Market
Square Arena and the league reviewed it
and says you know what that was an
offensive foul
no bucket Bulls you win yeah series over
in five that's kind of what they're
saying right there but I I understand
somebody watching and they want to you
know be the lifeguard for the sport or
they want to uphold the integrity I
understand you want to do that I can't
leagues should not allow that to
and once you are finished with your
round you're finished with your round
who ever noticed or didn't notice
whoever did something or didn't do
something that's it you're done there
has to be some amount of time that your
your scorecard stamped
whatever happened you got away with it
we move on I might even go as far as if
someone would have called in during the
tournament maybe a half hour later or
before she got done with her 18 holes
and reported it I'm maybe I'm ok with
that but a day later while she's
somewhere in Kabul with the trophy
Monmouth Beach chili and then oh she
gets the phone call by the way Lexie we
got to talk can you get on the next
flight and bring the trophy back here's
video proof of you moving your ball a
half a inch there's one thing I want to
bring up to you reg yes sir what
happened to the eye I was training well
first of all let me just say this
mountain bike competition in writing is
a contact sport it's you versus the
trail and the trail line Wow I was
training for a race in Fontana because I
was supposed to work all-star the final
four weekend and I was told I wasn't
working so I was like oh okay well
there's a race and then we go to Fontana
and pre ride the course which I was
doing that wasn't the problem
I did it which was very technical and
difficult so I did the course it was my
cool down afterwards I'm going down a
hill a fire road which I've gone down
many times before but the trail at the
bottom of it turned to sand it's like
quicksand so I'm going down at a pretty
good speed and it just stopped my bike
threw me over and everything did what it
was supposed to do the helmet the shades
but it was a pretty good fall so
fractured my scapula as you saw a little
shiner but if you never crash if you
never fall in mountain biking then
you're not a real mountain biker so it's
a badge and you learn from it and you
move on you're not it should happen
you're
not able to shoot for a while right well
it was my left
okay now you text me an hour ago saying
I definitely want to get into this MVP
Russell Westbrook conversation what is
it that you want to say about this
number a month ago maybe a month ago
Ferg a month it half ago we were talking
about Westbrook and were there any other
candidates all year long I've said
Westbrook was my MVP and remember that
four-game stretch he had when he lost to
I believe it was Portland twice at the
time they weren't in the playoffs then
he went lost the Phoenix and then they
lost a Dallas all in a row and I was
like if you're gonna be the MVP you
can't lose those four games in a row and
then they rebound it and they went on to
win like six or seven and he had you
know these unbelievable games I'm here
to say this if Westbrook does not win
MVP the NBA should fold I'm serious and
I know I heard a few of your comments
about people putting too much stock into
the triple-double man this is
unbelievable what this young man has has
done this year and seriously the league
is rigged if he does not win MVP he's
got to win MVP I'm putting that much
talk and what he does each and every
night okay but if Roz if Reggie if
harden averaged a triple-double would
you be saying the same thing he's two
rebounds away from doing that but then
go then go get the two rebounds then but
maybe that's not important to him it
feels like it's more important to
Russell Westbrook how is it more
important to Russell Westbrook and that
James Harden well I I think that given
what he's doing I think it feels like
Houston being a better team that it's
that's not part of what's going on
where's Westbrook it almost feels like
that's what he needs to do every single
game I'm going to go out and get a
triple-double to help my team Harden
doesn't have to do that I think in
Westbrook's mind he does have to do all
of those different things he has to have
assists and points and rebounds Harden
does not harden is two rebounds away
from a triple-double per game and I
thought are we going to penalize
Westbrook for what what you just said
should he be penalized for that because
but you know that triple doubles aren't
all created equal here and there are
harden games that aren't triple doubles
that are better than some of these
triple doubles with Russell Westbrook
his team is so much better this year
than last year I know that Westbrook
lost her rent but losing Durant allowed
him to do a whole lot more he doesn't
have to it's his team he does whatever
he wants harden has made his teammates
better with the number of assists he has
and their record I think that's why he's
gonna win it I'm fascinated with
Westbrook I understand you know what
this means in the history of the game
you know so how am i penalizing harden
because he's not averaging a
triple-double that he can't win the MVP
both are deserving along with LeBron
James I think he gets lost in the
shuffle here on the campaign that he's
had this season as well but to me it's a
two-man race Harden Westbrook so from
what I'm understanding you're going with
James Harden correct I think he'll win
it I'm going with Russell Westbrook and
I'm so far to say this okay if James
Harden wins I will donate $5,000 to your
charity choice of the charity of your
choice
that'd be the dance okay if I win I want
for a week-long show all y'all to wear
31 jerseys every single day for the for
our show that simple
okay I have no again I have no voting in
this like I don't vote for a VP I don't
think I'm just going I'm just going by
my opinion I think Wes Russell Westbrook
still winning VPD because this is
something that has not been done in 51
52 years yeah you got to take that into
consideration too but Oscar didn't even
win the MVP that year he did not I know
it was Russell and let's just go a step
further Wilt Chamberlain was averaging
50 points
not winning VP that year now it's been
brought to my attention by the dance can
we wear any Jersey that has the number
31 so Winfield Greg Maddux okay I will
say this yes all 30 ones that are in the
Hall of Fame so that would be Maddux
Winfield Winfield he is in the Baseball
Hall of Fame yes Mike Piazza famous 31
jerseys whoever is in a Hall of Fame
okay and whatever sport they do all week
long and or whoever your security is
okay okay okay all right is that fair I
love it
yes one other item the LeBron yelling at
Tristan Thompson last night during a
timeout then happen then yeah emotion I
got it I don't know it's it's it seems
like it's being made out to be a bigger
deal he does apologize about it but I
don't even I don't need the apology dude
you're playing you're playing hard what
happens you're yelling at each other hey
the way that the Cavs have played the
last three weeks you can see the sense
of desperation and they're not playing
up to expectations they've lost that
number one seed in the East to Boston
and you know they're not playing their
best going into the playoffs and there's
a sense of desperation and emotions
happen if I want you though if I give
you the cab's at the field in the East
right now I'm still taking LeBron James
okay if I gave what you're saying to me
is one of those things Boston Washington
and we are covering the Eastern
Conference Finals this year one of those
teams have to beat LeBron James in war
times yes
that's what to me that's what makes it
very very difficult you have to beat him
four times I like how you said LeBron
you didn't say the Cavs okay if I gave
you Golden State or the field in the
West it's a different story
I have to see how Kevin Durant comes
back he'll be
no he'll be Sydney he'll be he's never
had real a major injury like this before
had a foot injury yeah all right all
right so so type of it he did not have
these types of expectations upon him
because it's championship or bust right
yeah he's got it win a championship now
I want you to tell James Harden what our
bet is on Monday night next Monday night
when you don't lose rocketed watching
and listening because I am during the
Houston game on the 10th yeah it's not
like I'm rooting for Russell Westbrook
because I love James Harden too
I'm just looking at the whole body of
work a guy that's averaged a
triple-double all season long and the
numbers that have gone along to
accompany those numbers reg just love
what he's done now look what the Rockets
have done don't get me wrong just save
it just save it for Harden when you see
him
you know what to tell us anything okay
all right and you just be sure you guys
I'm ready
so Winfield Maddock grill grande fewers
Mike Piazza Oh
all week long Monday to Friday
y'all just with y'all jerseys yep and I
might even take down your Jersey out of
the frame and and wear that it says it
says break glass in case of emergency
this would be all right who do you have
tonight by the way who will or who do I
want who's gonna win North Carolina will
will probably win but it could you see
Gonzaga win it I mean you know I'm five
minutes from Pepperdine that will help
the WCC conference that will help
Pepperdine that helps you know these
Cinderella teams so it would be nice to
see Gonzaga win but North Carolina
probably should and will win all right
all right enjoy yeah enjoy the week off
you're the best Thank You Reggie that's
Reggie elevations Miller all fired up
there and I'm I want people to
understand I I'm what did I tell you
about Russell Westbrook
that's the one guy I would pay to see I
just tried to handicap how the voters
are gonna see this and I think they're
going to vote James Harden if Russell
Westbrook wins awesome I couldn't care
less the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience